president obama has a very enlightened
position on the earth and i'd be happy
to tell you what i think it's is
particularly good about it and and shows
a lot of promise
first and foremost there have been law
of there been proposed legislation for
many many years now to restore the
deduction for artists gifts to museums
which at the present time artists cannot
deduct a full market value of the work
that they give they can only deduct the
cost of materials so that's literally
the cost of the canvas and the
stretchers and the paint if a collector
buys the painting for ten thousand
dollars and it becomes worth ten million
and he or she were to give that painting
away they could claim the full market
value this the legislation prohibiting
artists from being able to give away
their work goes back to Nixon at the end
of the Eisenhower administration he
tried to deduct taking a million dollar
deduction for his vice-presidential
papers which I don't need to remind you
Americans had already paid to produce in
the first place and Congress was was so
outraged by this ballsy attempt on on
Nixon's
effort to be able to duck this stuff
that they hastily wrote a law that said
that you can no longer to duck the work
of your own hand in subsequent years the
IRS interpreted that law to mean
composers scores writers manuscripts
painters paintings sculptures better so
all of a sudden museums libraries
cultural institutions were faced with
with the with these gifts essentially
drying up I have to say though that and
that even though we get no deduction I
give four or five hundred thousand
dollars for the work away a year for no
tax deduction I'd like to know how much
a lot of those people in the stock
market would give away if they didn't
get a tax deduction but that's beside
the point
any right Obama has said that that he
will he has supported it as a as a
senator and he will now support it as
president and try and get that
overturned and restore artists for full
market value now one of the most
perverse things about the way our system
works is while I'm alive my work is
valueless except for the cost of
materials the moment I die
IRS moves in and and charges my heirs my
family the full market value of the work
not what it could be sold for but the
full market value you cannot sell enough
work because dealers take a commission
to pay the taxes the inheritance tax
plus you have to pay the tax on the work
you're selling to pay the
Aaron's tax so it's such an unfair
burden for artisan horse families we're
very much like family farmers
we're family farmer would like to pass
on the farm to their children who would
just want to continue to farm now
they've got a so off Anchorage to pay
the inheritance tax and I know farmer
where the grandfather died they had to
sell off a bunch of land and then the
father got it and then he died within
just a few years and then the son from
that they had they were paying that
inheritance tax twice and so a gland to
do it and that's it's that sort of thing
that happening to artists all the time
so that legislation would be extremely
important other things that he has said
that he's in favor of are the is an art
core that would be something akin to the
Peace Corps or something else in which
people who artists could be put into the
school system right now in Brooklyn
there are hundreds of great Russian
violinists who emigrated this country
who cannot teach in the public school
system because they don't have teacher
certification they can't teach the
schools cannot pay them because they're
required to have teacher certification
the government could pay these wonderful
artists and musicians work get around
that limitation of our certification and
put them into the schools and what a
great thing that would be for the
educational system in New York City in
the budget the fiscal crisis in the 70s
late seventies the first thing to go is
art music there was no more art music in
public schools and someone like Aggie
guns stepped in and formed studio in a
school and
board member of that foundation as well
and what that foundation does is pay
artists so that they can then go work in
the public schools so this is extremely
important I think and something that
would benefit people in every state and
in every constituency from and you know
the poorest communities to to the
richest but so I think that's extremely
important restoring of the National
Endowment would be extremely important
the National Endowment was started by
Johnson but it really grew more under
the Republicans it grew more under Nixon
than any other president and it was it
had bipartisan support it was seen as
something everybody could agree on why
yes we should be putting money into the
into the arts and then the public
television and all these things and I I
journeyed for the in the national battle
for the Arts in the individual artist
grants six of us that for six days and
looked at 60,000 slides from artists in
every country
I reckon every state we looked at many
of those slides two or three times and I
never felt better about anything I've
ever done than giving this government
money away if the government spent the
rest of its money as well as a National
Endowment spent it in rewarding artists
and writers and that we would be a lot
better shape and but beyond the money
the ten or fifteen thousand dollars that
we gave to each person
this was their government recognizing
them peers other artists deciding that
they deserve
this money and that their government was
bestowing it on them and this was in the
middle of the Vietnam War and where
people were a lot of people in the art
community we're not particularly happy
with what their government did and yet
they saw that that this is something
that government can do it can recognize
talent it can encourage people and it
and it's incredibly important to an
artist that Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval that comes from a jury of your
peers deciding that your work is
important enough to be recognized by
your government and by the way you're
also getting this money very very
important very important it's much more
valuable than the money itself so these
and other things that that Obama has
weighed in on I think would would really
make a great difference in the cultural
life of